I'm here with Danny O'Dwyer I'm Peter
Brown gamescom 2015 is under way you can
see behind us Danny was got chance to
play need for speed and I don't know
there's been a lot of these games over
the past decade why should I care about
this point this is need for speed the
fantastically popular game based on the
movie based on the series of video games
that everyone's for looking forward to
it said in ventura Bay which over the
course of one endless nice wait the
minute it never ends you're stuck in
this night forever so how long is this
game like seven hours no it's not real
time it's it's just that there is no day
there is no day/night cycle it's all
night which kind of explains why there's
also not much traffic in ventura may as
well but the story stuff we've seen some
of the little sort of FMV intro or FMV
story beats that then sort of bleed into
gameplay because the car was there I saw
some more of those that kind of has that
like it's the crazy night where crazy
things are happening it's okay how
accessible is this game because need for
speed is not what most people would
consider a simulation racer and I'm
guessing nothing has changed in that
regard I've actually done some pretty
interesting things here and you're right
very Arkady style game and they're
making this game for like they're doing
that whole thing where they're making a
first car enthusiast so they have you
know your ability to make your car look
really pretty with like liveries and
whatnot and you can just you know by
like stock liveries or you can like you
can just like tweak overall there's a
drift and gripmeter at the top so you
can just go into the drift or you can go
into the grip but underneath that
there's actually a lot of like tire
pressure changing your diff changing to
Canberra the wheels so when you're doing
that it can that sort of changes the
overall thing as well as but if you
don't want to do that you can just go on
top and I actually think I somebody who
like I play the breath of the Isle of
burnout paradise but then they also play
games like you know project cars I
actually think it's a pretty neat system
like how much it actually affects the
grip and rip is questionable and
actually play this game so I can tell
how it feels but I thought from a purely
trying to make this game good for people
who want to tweak everything down to the
factory like you can like change the
rear rims against the front rims which
apparently is a new fad that's happening
right now in car customization at you
can also just go
whatever I'll just want like a drift
machine and it's red so it's pretty cool
scalable I heard you talking about the
game's icons i take it that they look
really nice now and very pretty no I've
decided at them he's like check out the
icons somewhere like yeah it's a menu
for racing day what what's going on
behind the television there was like a
fixture ken block and some other
gentleman so iconic people within racing
so I guess the game is like split into
different tiers of racing from like you
know drifting with like ken Block to
like you know really tuning your car a
lot and the mission structure is done
that way so you'll get phone calls while
you're driving around for like random
missions you guys like random drivers
coming up like trying to chase you and
stuff there's the cops but then there's
also like these tiered missions and
every time you go into one of those your
kind of progressing towards being that
next icon in you know in those five
slots in a one night it was actually
really impressive you can manage to be
like better than ken Block in like seven
hours before that that's pretty
impressive so that's that's our kind of
like fundamental like big tentpole I
guess is that they're like trying to say
this is game were like we're really
taking it back to like actual real-life
street races but I will also say that
the CG acting and whatnot is still
really self serious and a kind of a this
is dumb but I'm into a kind of way
alright well that's the new need for
speed when's it coming out you know nope
no we have no idea but i can tell you
when more games com content is cutting
out today tomorrow the day after that
stay tuned to gamespot com for all the
great gaming news coming to you endless
nights